wenn alle Produkte mit dem Stempel made
in China aus unseren Wohnungen
verschwenden dann sehen die wohl
ziemlich leer aus wir sind der größte
Handelspartner Chinas abhängig von einer
Autokratie seit Sonntag findet in Peking
der Volkskongress der Kommunistischen
Partei statt alle fünf Jahre werden die
Mitglieder dort eingeschworen um das
Land noch mächtiger zu machen durch
Corona hat sich China abgeschottet
Menschen ewig in den Lockdown gezwungen
totale Überwachung Drohungen gegenüber
Taiwan Menschenrechtsverletzungen in
Hongkong und gegen die oliguren welche
Strategie brauchen wir Umgang mit diesem
Reich China und der Westen gefährliche
Abhängigkeit unser Thema in der
phönix-runde
Phoenix Runde
guten Abend ich begrüße ganz herzlich
aus Berlin und darf in meine Gäste
vorstellen bei uns ist wie die Jensen
sie ist die stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende der
FDP-Bundestagsfraktion und sie ist
stellvertretende Vorsitzende der
Deutschen chinesischen Parlamentarier
Gesellschaften frankieren ist freier
Journalist und China Korrespondent dort
lebt er seit 1994 und der ist uns jetzt
zugeschaltet aus Peking und ich begrüße
Volker Dreier er ist
außenwirtschaftschef und Mitglied der
Hauptgeschäftsführung des deutschen
Industrie- und handelskammertags und
Chieming ist bei uns freier Journalist
erst in Peking geboren lebt seit 1987 in
Deutschland und berät unter anderem auch
deutsche Kommunen zur Zusammenarbeit mit
China und herrschi mit ihnen würde ich
gerne beginnen wir sehen diesen
Parteitag der findet alle fünf Jahre
statt ein großer Aufmarsch ein großes
Ereignis was bedeutet das in China die
in dieser Zeit wenn dieser Parteitag
stattfindet wird sehen jetzt auch gleich
mal ein paar Bilder dazu bitte
es bedeutet natürlich zuerst der alle
fünf Jahre die Weichen Stimmungen Oma zu
unterstreichen die gleichen Stellungen
wird nicht für alle fünf Jahre geändert
aber sie werden alle fünf Jahre mal
demonstriert welche
Weichenstellungen es gibt und in welchem
Sinne des zu verstehen sind und in
diesem Jahr besondere das Besondere in
diesem Jahr ist
ursprüngliche wäre eine Führungswechsel
vorgesehen der würde in diesem Jahr mit
höchster Wahrscheinlichkeit gar nicht
stattfinden wir haben gerade die Bilder
ja gesehen also wir sehen she sing Ping
wie mächtig ist er im Moment
amtlich gesehen ist der natürlichen
weite sehr sehr mächtig er hatte alle
drei wichtigsten Ämter auf sich geeinigt
und das vierte fünf Jahre lang so
bleiben
sachpolitisch gesehen ist die Situation
weitaus komplexer also zum Beispiel
hatte er sich in der Sachpolitik selten
wirklich durchgesetzt wie zum Beispiel
diese Geschichte mit der covid-politik
aber das war seine Linie auch Shanghai
fünf Wochen in Lockdown zu schicken das
war nicht besonders gut aber Russlands
Politik ist ein weiterer Entscheidung
von ihm das das geht nach hinten los und
dass das was sieht man ja heute da wird
man abwarten müssen wie weit seine
Politik oder seine machte sich in der
fachpolitik dann weiter
durchsetzt oder vielleicht auch nicht
aber er ist auf jeden Fall der Mann an
der Spitze mit dem man umgehen muss
fragen wir mal nach pekingheisieren der
große Volkskongress mit über 2000
Delegierten die da sind also wie ist das
wenn dieser Volkskongress stattfindet in
der Zeit ist das dann auch das alles
beherrschende Thema in China
ja natürlich schon also das ist ja
dadurch dass das alle fünf Jahre
stattfindet schauen die Leute dann schon
hin und wollen wissen wie es weitergeht
und man sieht es ja auch an den
konsumzahlen das heißt die Konsumenten
haben jetzt erstmal gewartet mit dem
Autokauf mit dem Wohnungskauf und mit
anderen mit anderen
konsumtätigkeiten und schauen sich
erstmal an was da passiert weil es eben
so ein ungewöhnlicher Vorgang ist dass
der Staatspräsident beziehungsweise der
Partei-Chef nicht nach zwei Amtsperioden
abtritt sondern jetzt verlängert und man
hat ja auch das Gefühl dass es hinter
den Kulissen da sehr hoch hergeht am
Montag hat der Vizepremier dann erst
einmal gesagt alle müssen zusammenhalten
oder einer der Vizepremiers das ist ja
normalerweise ein Zeichen dafür das
kennen wir auch aus Deutschland das
nicht doch nicht alle zusammenhalten
also insofern ist das schon ein Ereignis
was große Aufmerksamkeit erregt und wie
Macht bewusst auch gerade gegenüber dem
besten zeigt sich China da oder die
Partei
naja in dieser Hinsicht hat es sogar
einen kleinen Unterschied gegeben weil
bisher hat man eher gesagt man möchte
gerne seinen eigenen Weg gehen und sich
von niemand Andern sagen lassen wie
dieser Weg aussehen soll jetzt in der
Rede von cheatenping wurde deutlich dass
China führen möchte in der Welt und das
ist ein Modell sein möchte für
andere Länder andere aufstrebende Länder
das ist ein ziemlich neuer Ton und auch
ein neuer Ton in der chinesischen
Geschichte China war ja oder hat sich ja
als das Reich der Mitte bezeichnet das
heißt man hat sich um die Nachbarländer
nicht so viel gekümmert das waren
Vasallen und Barbaren und insofern ist
dieser dieses rausstreben das ist schon
ein neues Element und da wird auch die
Linie von banks her Ping abgelöst die
dass man bescheiden sein soll dass man
lieber unauffälliger auftreten soll und
weniger stark als man eigentlich ist
okay also deutlich macht bewusster zeigt
sich da China vor Jensen was bedeutet
das denn für den Westen und für unseren
Umgang damit
das bedeutet erstmal dass wir anerkennen
müssen dass cheating ping und die
Kommunistische Partei nicht in
Legislaturperioden denkt und auch
entsprechend müssen wir als Westen
darauf reagieren wir haben
Bundesregierungen in den letzten Jahren
Jahrzehnten erlebt die in ihren vier
jahresrhythmen gedacht haben und
vergessen haben die lange Linie
vorauszusehen wenn eine kommunistische
Partei ja doch auch sehr sehr offen
darüber gesprochen hat wie die diese
lange Linie und der der Kreislauf die
Art und Weise wie das reicht der Mitte
sich Ford entwickeln will wie der Westen
darauf reagiert wie wir politisch darauf
reagieren und deswegen glaube ich ist es
wichtig dass die Bundesregierung sich
jetzt beispielsweise einer
china-strategie widmet die zum Beispiel
nicht nur im Auswärtigen Amt geschrieben
wird sondern die verschiedene
Komponenten verschiedene Themenbereiche
Ministerien
zusammenbindet weil jetzt eben auch
nicht nur eine Frage ist wie die
Außenministerin derzeit mit der Lage in
China umgeht sondern es ist eine Lage
genau auch für Kommunen für die
Bundesländer für den wissenschafts- und
Forschungsbereich und da würde ich mir
wünschen dass wir mit der China
Strategie einen Beitrag dazu leisten
können zu zeigen dass wir gewappnet sind
und dass wir realistisch auf das uns
mögliche blicken und das möglichst in
einer Allianz von Demokratien in der
Welt weil China versucht ja zu zeigen
dass das Konzept von Demokratie nicht
mehr zeitgemäß ist auf unsere
Herausforderungen
systemwettbewerb auf jeden Fall und wir
haben eine ganz starke Abhängigkeit
wirtschaftlicher Dreier wie abhängig
sind wir von China wie stark brauchen
wir China oder braucht China und sie
haben in ihrer Anmoderation gesagt dass
jede und jeder von uns zu Hause und auch
anderswo im Konsum täglichen Leben
Produkte aus aus China verwendet
china hat uns auch und nicht nur uns der
ganzen Welt auch über vielleicht 15
Jahre
ein Zeitraum verschafft in dem
Preissteigerungen für solche Produkte
relativ gering waren jetzt merken wir
wie in China die Dinge nicht so laufen
wie verengpässe
Auswirkungen dieser
nullcovit-strategie mit langen lockdowns
in Shanghai insbesondere in diesem Jahr
und und auch deshalb Preise steigen und
nicht nur wegen der
energieversorgungskrise und
energiepreiskriegekrise die wir durch
den brutalen russischen Angriffskrieg in
der Ukraine erleiden müssen also diese
Preissteigerung zeigen umgekehrt auch
dass wir alle davon profitiert haben
oder zumindest sehr viele Menschen
weltweiten sind wir extrem abhängig also
ich
ist es ganz wichtig zu unterscheiden
Beschaffungsmärkte wo welche Produkte
kriegen wir aus China die wir nicht wenn
wir sie nicht kriegen nicht mehr
weiterverarbeiten können und da geht es
um bestimmte Rohstoffe wir haben eine
Studie mit dem Ifo-Institut gemacht und
da haben wir von 9 essentiellen
Rohstoffen sieben identifiziert bei
denen China die Top unter den Top 5
Anbietern weltweit sind und dann geht es
um Rohstoffe die wir brauchen für die
Energiewende für die Digitalisierung für
die mobilitätswende die wir in
Deutschland Europa eine West in Welt
hoffentlich anstreben wollen da sind wir
abhängig Absatzmärkte des
fehlgescholtenen Beispiel aus der
Automobilindustrie und aus anderen
Bereichen wo Umsätze generiert werden
vom weltweiten Umsatz in China von von
50 Prozent und und darüber
das wäre natürlich wirtschaftlich
gesehen nicht gut wenn das Weg viele ja
weil das unser Lebens unseren Wohlstand
dann unterminieren würde aber es wäre
nicht so essentiell wie auf diesen
Beschaffungsmärkten da ist es wichtiger
und da liegt es an uns da kommen ja
Rohstoffe oder sie sind rohstoffvorgang
mit vielen anderen Ländern wo wir den
anderen Ländern Angebote machen wo wir
es versäumt haben die letzten 20 Jahre
und China hat diese Angebote gemacht
hessieren wie jetzt haben wir gehört wie
abhängig wir sind von China wie abhängig
ist China von Deutschland
naja China ist natürlich auch abhängig
von Deutschland weil es sehr viele
Produkte nach Deutschland verkauft
wenn man sich jetzt mal die Zahlen
anschaut dann haben die Chinesen im Juli
das ist jetzt weltweit
ein Handelsbilanzüberschuss von 100
Milliarden US-Dollar gemacht das heißt
das ist ein neuer Rekord sie werden so
wie es aussieht in diesem Jahr die eine
Billion
Handelsbilanzüberschuss
übersteigen das bedeutet Sie haben eine
Billion mehr
verkauft als Sie eingekauft haben und
das ist natürlich für die chinesische
Wirtschaft sehr wichtig vor allem in
Zeiten wie im Moment wo der Binnenkonsum
auf dem man sich eigentlich immer
stärker verlassen möchte eben
eingebrochen ist und die Leute abwarten
und wir im Moment noch nicht wissen ist
das jetzt ein abwarten oder ist es
tatsächlich ein vertrauensbr das müssen
wir eben jetzt sehen wenn der wenn die
parteitagung zu Ende ist und die
covid-maßnahmen dann hoffentlich langsam
lockert werden ob
die Konjunktur die Binnenkonjunktur
wieder anzieht weil traditionell waren
die Chinesen eigentlich immer für
V-förmige Krisen bekannt also es ging
ganz schnell nach unten tief nach unten
und dann ging es ganz schnell wieder
hoch so war das 2020 oder
2008/2009 bei der Weltfinanzkrise jetzt
haben wir ein U und die Frage ist wie
breit wird dieses
okay ich würde hier gerne hansieren
absolut beipflichten China ist
sicherlich so abhängig auch von uns das
heißt von der westlichen Welt als
Absatzmarkt weil die eigenen Nachfrage
nicht mit dem Schritt hält was man sich
eigentlich vorgenommen hat und außerdem
ein Großteil des angesparten Vermögens
der Chinesen liegt im Ausland 3,2
Billionen
US-Dollar hat China in ausländischen
Anleihen insbesondere in den USA
angelegt und käme es zu irgendeinem
Vorfall stünden die auch zu Disposition
aber wenn wir jetzt von einem
systemwettbewerb sprechen was wir vorhin
schon angesprochen haben Frau Jensen
sollten wir versuchen diese Abhängigkeit
die wir jetzt gehört haben diese
Abhängigkeit zu minimieren ich würde es
unter dem Schlagwort die diversifizieren
fassen ich glaube man sollte realistisch
analysieren und das müssen wir jetzt
machen ist vollkommen richtig
angesprochen worden eigentlich wurde es
die letzten
20 Jahre versäumt gewissermaßen einen
China Stresstest zu machen in Bereichen
wo wir Stück für Stück merken das
Abhängigkeiten bestehen die bestehen ja
nach wie vor auch in beide Richtungen
auch das wurde ausgeführt manchmal
stärker manchmal weniger stark ich
glaube wir werden nicht in irgendeine
Richtung kommen dass wir das Wirtschaft
sich Stück für Stück aus China
zurückzieht da wo wir einfach davon
abhängig sind aber ich glaube wir
sollten uns breiter aufstellen das macht
jeder Bürger ja im Grunde zu Hause auch
wenn Geld investiert versucht man nicht
alles auf eine Karte zu setzen und so
würde ich mir wünschen dass auch die
Politik und zwar nicht nur in
Deutschland sondern insgesamt
internationale Politik
Risikobewertungen vornimmt wenn wir in
wenn hier in china investiert wird dann
gibt es für Unternehmen nicht die
Möglichkeit den Grund und Boden zu
erwerben auf dem zum Beispiel das
Unternehmensgelände oder dass die die
Halle steht das ist ein Risiko was man
so gar nicht abbilden kann weil wir ja
gar nicht Essen in Zukunft wie die
Kommunistische Partei an bestimmten
Stellen vielleicht politisch in Zukunft
entscheidet das heißt wir würden
in eine Situation kommen die man auch
gar nicht unbedingt
wie haftungstechnisch klären kann
risikotechnisch bewerten kann ich würde
dafür plädieren dass wir diversifizieren
und zum Beispiel das Stichwort Seltene
Erden aufnehmen China ist momentan das
Land was vor allen Dingen in der in der
Verarbeitung in der Raffinierung
seltener Erden
an der Top Stelle steht Australien ist
aber ein Ansprechpartner ein
demokratisches Land mit dem wir da
deutlich mehr in Gespräche treten
sollten ich glaube so muss man die Sache
angehen und wir brauchen mehr China
Kompetenz
günstiger ist und wenn ich als Konsument
dann mich entscheiden muss entscheide
ich mich meist dann für das günstigste
aber wenn ich da einhalten darf das ich
glaube das ist genau der Fehler den wir
machen den kurzfristigen gewinnen oder
die kurzfristige
kosteneinspar glaube ich sorgt dafür
dass wir langfristig möglicherweise
Schaden nehmen und ich glaube in dieser
Balance sollte man zukünftig politische
Entscheidungen mehr abwägen was würden
Sie raten wenn man Geschäfte machen will
mit China was wäre jetzt sinnvoll weil
wir haben ja jetzt durch die Erfahrung
mit Russland
stellen wir uns ja noch mal viel stärker
die Frage sollen wir uns so abhängig
machen von einem Land das nicht an
unsere Werte glaubt ich würde jetzt eine
andere Art von Abhängigkeit der
thematisieren die er ohnehin schon
entstanden ist die Abhängigkeit
Deutschlands von der NATO zum Beispiel
ja die NATO handelte ein einstimmig
gegen Russland in dem Krieg in den
Ukraine China unterstützt zumindest ab
jetzt doch
Russland also das ist schon eine
geopolitische Gegenposition klar
geworden und diese Position wird sich in
der eine oder anderen vom fortsetzen zum
Beispiel das chinesische Marine mit der
russischen
pazifischer Flotte militärische Routen
abfahren gegen die USA gegen Japan gegen
Südkorea und diese drogebeten die gehen
über Taiwan Konflikte weit hinaus und
diese drogebeten haben natürlich eine
Signal auch an Nordkorea das heißt so
lange Deutschland in dem Bündnis der
NATO bleibt und es wird auch so bleiben
solange gibt es eine geopolitische
Abhängigkeit von Deutschland und diese
geopolitische Abhängigkeit
mit der wirtschaftliche Abhängigkeit
gegenüber wie wirkt man das ab wie kann
man noch sagen gut also jetzt uns ist
unser wirtschaftliches Leben viel
wichtiger als die geopolitische
Verpflichtung wir vergessen erst mal die
NATO wir machen erstmal die Geschäfte
mit China wir merken zum Beispiel ist
auch mit Russland die die gasgeschäfte
Putin bietet Deutschland ist billigen
Gas an aber in Deutschland kann gar
nicht darauf reagieren kann nicht sagen
ja weil es uns billiger ist kaufen wir
den den Gas jetzt von Russland
vielleicht nicht die Rechte in dieser
Schafe Form aber in einer anderen Form
wird es so weit kommen zum Beispiel
Elektroniker Japan ist ein Hightech
elektronischer Resonanz wenn Japan
Deutschland auffordert bitte tritt China
nicht zu nah wie wird Deutschland auf
Japan reagieren wenn die jetzt also
geopolitische Erklärungen abgegeben
werden nicht nur von Frau Werbung der
Außenministerin sondern auch von
Luftwaffe der Bundeswehr bestehen auf
die japanischen Seite wird es den
wirtschaftspolitischer Konsequenzen
bedeuten wenn Deutschland sich
verpflichten würde und sagen wir stehen
eben auf der Seite von Japaner egal
[Musik]
abwägen aber ich hessieren sie wollten
sich noch eben zu Wort melden
zum Thema Diversifizierung das ist
richtig und wichtig das Problem ist nur
wohin diversifizieren wir und da ist
eben die Situation dass es zu China und
das ist nun mal so das kann man bedauern
keine gleichwertige Alternative gibt
Indien ist es nicht die Asien Länder
sind es auch nicht das ein oder andere
Land könnte es werden also man kann ein
bisschen was verschieben aber im großen
Stil ist es sehr schwierig weil eben
China und der chinesische Absatzmarkt so
groß ist das muss man realistisch sehen
wir würden uns natürlich wünschen dass
Indien genauso stark wäre wie China aber
das ist eben nicht so
und wenn wir uns dann stattdessen
entscheidend zurückzuziehen dann müssen
wir eben auch das Preisschild dran
machen und ich glaube das ist eben dann
das politische Problem in einer
Demokratie wie Deutschland oder in der
in Europa dass man dann sagen muss die
Inflation wird dann noch steigen ja
Dreier hat das ja eben angedeutet
also dieses entkoppeln diese Größe
Unabhängigkeit die gibt es nicht umsonst
sondern wir müssen bereit sein einen
Preis dafür zu bezahlen und haben dann
unter Umständen eine Inflation eben die
nicht 10% beträgt sondern vielleicht 20
oder 25 Prozent und da ist eben die
politische Bereitschaft dazu da ist aber
so müssen wir das diskutieren wir können
nicht sagen wir müssen uns jetzt
zurückziehen und nicht Eis dafür nennen
aber nach der Erfahrung gerade jetzt mit
Russland Herr Dreier also hätte man
vielleicht vorher auch gesagt dass es
ist günstig das Glas aus Russland zu
bekommen unser jetzt ist das Preisschild
ja noch viel größer durch den Konflikt
also müsste man nicht jetzt auf eine
andere Art versuchen sich doch
unabhängiger zu machen
unsere wirtschaftliche Abhängigkeit von
China ist wirklich anders als die von
Russland und
angesichts der auch wirklich jetzt
dieser strösen Erfahrungen in der
Beziehung zu Russland angesichts dieses
angriffskriegs
würde ich auch empfehlen China nicht zu
sehr mit Russland zu vergleichen und
unsere Schlussfolgerungen darzuziehen
wir haben ein volkswirtschaftlicher ein
gesellschaftlicher Abhängigkeit von
russischen Energielieferungen in
Deutschland deshalb ist es und in Europa
und deshalb ist es auch wichtig und
richtig dass jetzt so viel auch an
staatlichen Maßnahmen gemacht wird um
uns gut über diesen Winter zu bringen
das heißt Gesellschaft und Unternehmen
so dass wir nächstes Jahr vielleicht den
Perspektive haben
dann in die weitere Zukunft zu blicken
die Abhängigkeit von China ist bei
manchen Unternehmen groß im Sinne auch
das Absatzmarktes diese unternehmen wir
haben gerade eine Umfrage laufen
diversifizieren schon ist genauso wie
hessieren sagt das geschieht unter
Kosteneinsatz und ich halte es nach wie
vor und wir halten es für richtig mit
China weiterhin natürlich wirtschaftlich
im Dialog zu bleiben das jetzt
aufzugeben wäre also ökonomisch gesehen
also wirklich also mehr als nur ein
Schlag ins Kontor das andere ist auch
politisch mit den wirtschaftlichen
Beziehungen haben wir auch eine gewisse
sagen wir mal argumentative Kraft in
China hoffentlich das sollte man nicht
aufgeben und wir haben das Argument wir
haben wir handeln durch Handeln das hat
nicht funktioniert mit Russland
naja es gibt Leute die sagen es ist
Wandel durch Annäherung nicht durch
Handel aber wir haben geopolitische
Herausforderungen oder oder
globale Herausforderung wie den
Klimaschutz die wir ohne China überhaupt
richtig lösen können und wir haben
Themen die darunter fallen mit
Energieeffizienz und Umwelttechnologie
wo wir auch wirtschaftlich China
weiterhin etwas anbieten sollten um
globale Themen zu adressieren und
hoffentlich auch beginnen zu lösen und
ein bisschen naiv gegenüber China die
Nachrichtendienste haben am Montag dem
parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium
Bericht erstattet und haben gewarnt dass
man die Bedrohung von China dass man der
nicht ausreichend betrachtet Beachtung
schenken würde und der Chef des
Verfassungsschutzes Thomas Haldenwang
hat gesagt russland ist der Sturm oder
wenn Russland der Sturm es ist China ist
der Klimawandel und hat noch mal ganz
klar gesagt wir sollten nicht zu
vertrauenselig und zu naiv sein aber das
sind das sind wir nicht also das mit der
Naivität würde ich nicht gerne stehen
lassen es gibt unter dem Stichwort
Reziprozität wirklich viel was auch von
der Europäischen Union schon seit
geraumer Zeit unternommen wird und wo
wir wirklich viele Defensive Maßnahmen
gestärkt haben weil wir gerade nicht
naiv sind ein Moment ich würde gerne
Frau Jensen aus der Politik dazu gerne
hören also wenn man jetzt sagt und dann
Herrn Ski und dann Sie also ich mache
das Beispiel kommen green and on
investment compians of cream and on
Investment das zeigt wurde noch quasi
als Abschluss von Kanzlerin Merkel
verhandelt auf EU-Ebene mit China ein
Abkommen was jetzt auf Eis liegt
aufgrund von gegenseitigen Sanktionen
und zwar berechtigterweise auf Eis liegt
weil wir glaube ich ganz stark aufpassen
müssen dass die Volksrepublik bzw die
Kommunistische Partei genau bei der
Debatte selbstverständlich brauchen wir
die Volksrepublik wenn es darum geht den
Klimawandel dem Klimawandel zu begegnen
wir dürfen uns aber nicht in dieser Form
erpressen lassen dass die Kommunistische
Partei nur am Tisch sitzt wenn sie dann
über wirtschaftliche Prosperität mit uns
sprechen kann über Armutsbekämpfung aber
nicht über Menschenrechte das ist so ein
bisschen die glaube ich die Sache ich
glaube auch nicht also ich habe es nicht
naiv verstanden ich glaube aber wir
müssen aufpassen dass wir in dem
narrativ und unseren unserer
zielbeschreibung einheitlich auf
europäischer Ebene sprechen mit
Demokratien weltweit wir stehen
definitiv an der Seite Japans wir müssen
aber uns viel viel stärker absprechen
denn das macht ja die Volksrepublik
genauso auch mit mit vermeintlichen
Partnern wobei ich sagen würde am im
Falle Russlands die je ekelhafter dieser
Krieg wird desto schwieriger glaube ich
fällt es auch hier sich noch an die
Seite Russlands zu stellen jetzt haben
wir ja gerade letzte Woche dann oder
diese Woche eine letzte Woche das
Abstimmungsverhalten in den Vereinten
Nationen gesehen da Tina sich enthalten
das ist schon ein Zeichen was wir glaube
ich in wahrnehmen müssen dass das hi
widerstrebt sehr sehr eindeutig und sehr
Augsburger können an der Seite der
Föderation zu stehen und ich glaube das
muss man aufnehmen und diese Brüche die
muss man bearbeiten ich glaube wir
sollten tatsächlich auch etwas
längerfristig überlegen was in der Ver
Zeit falsch gelaufen ist zum Beispiel
die Diversifizierung
es ist ja klar dass in auschinesischen
Küstenstreifen die Arbeitskosten längst
so Frucht sind das europäische
Länder mit streiten können Tschechien
zum Beispiel Slowakei zum Beispiel
Ungarn zum Beispiel sie sind jetzt schon
viel billiger in der Produktion als in
China aber die Investitionen der
Europäischen Union insbesondere der
westlichen Ländern gehen eben nicht
massiv genug dorthin sie bauen dort eben
nicht genügend Infrastruktur auf sie
gehen alle nach China weil eben diese
große Produktionskapazitäten natürlich
die eine sortimentfähigkeit schaffen
kein Land kann so viel sofort liefern
wie China
das ist ein auch ein ökonomischer Fehler
den man lernen muss den beschädigt die
diese wische gerade Länder diese V4 die
haben glaube ich 70 Millionen Einwohner
ja also
deutsche Wirtschaft ist unglaublich
investiert in diesen Ländern aber ich
möchte gerne alles schon sie sie sagen
ja zwei Faktoren ich bin ganz
einverstanden der Faktor Markt da stimme
ich Ihnen zu der Markt ist zu klein der
Faktor der Produktionsstandort ist eine
andere Faktor ja wir haben natürlich
nicht nur eine Abhängigkeit von China
wegen des Absatzmarktes wir haben jetzt
ja auch ein Abhängigkeit folgende
Produktionskapazitäten das heißt also
wenn zum Beispiel jetzt eine im Winter 2
Millionen Paare von bestimmte Schuhe
gebraucht werden kann kaum jemand in
Ungarn 2 Millionen Schuhe innerhalb
einer Woche liefern das kann China ohne
Probleme machen das ist auch ein
Abhängigkeit
auch die Automobilhersteller die sagen
eigentlich schon seit 20 Jahren wir sind
abhängig von China und wir sind abhängig
von China ich nehme jetzt
Automobilindustrie von von Japan wenn
man nach ihrem Indien geht sind 1885
Prozent der Autor Autos die dort laufen
von Japaner was haben die deutschen
Automobilindustrie in den Jahren gemacht
in Indien wenn sie mich gar nicht erst
anfangen diese mag zu erschließen und
wenn sie jetzt beklagen wir können gar
nicht mehr nach Indien gehen weil der
Markt nicht da ist ja legte sich daran
dass man den marktteil noch lange nicht
vorbereitet hat für eine stärkere
Unabhängigkeit von China und dass man
sich stärker zurückzieht wenn ich das
richtig denke vielfältigung also das
dass man auch in der Markt Erschließung
damit beginnen muss und zwar massiv
beginnen muss natürlich war China am
Anfang genauso schwierig wie Indien
jetzt ich würde gerne mal auf den Punkt
kommen massieren sie wollten jetzt auch
gerne was zu sagen diese Frage inwieweit
dieses diese aufstrebende
wirtschaftsmaschine dann doch
ein sicher eine Sicherheitsbedrohung für
uns darstellt so so haben es die die
Nachrichtendienste auf jeden Fall noch
mal klargestellt
und dass wir da dass wir das nicht
auch tun schon alleine auf Nummer Sicher
zu um auf nummer sicher zu sein die
Frage ist was wir in dieser Situation
machen und
eines kann es glaube ich nicht sein so
groß die Unterschiede auch sein mögen
wir müssen mehr denn je miteinander
reden und uns austauschen und verstehen
die die Strategien der jeweiligen Seite
das tun die Amerikaner unsere
amerikanischen Freunde übrigens sehr
sehr intensiv
da gibt es einen sehr engen Austausch in
Europa und in Deutschland sehe ich das
nicht
es fängt jetzt gerade erst wieder an
aber da hat man eine ganze Weile
geschmollt als dann die Sanktionen
wechselseitig begonnen haben da sind die
Amerikaner sehr viel professioneller die
halten die politische Hitze hoch und
runter versuchen Sie so viel wie möglich
miteinander zu reden das gipfelte dann
sogar im Sommer diesen Jahres hat es ein
Treffen gegeben zwischen dem
Außenpolitik Spezialisten young und dem
Sicherheitsberater Sullivan die haben
sich dann Luxemburg getroffen in Brüssel
wollte niemand Herrn Yang sehen ich
glaube das geht nicht wir müssen
miteinander reden wir müssen
Gemeinsamkeiten finden wir müssen
natürlich auch sehen wo die Unterschiede
sind und wenn wir Unterschiede haben und
da haben wir ja viele gerade im Bereich
der Menschenrechte da müssen wir uns
zusammensetzen und darüber reden
ich habe nicht den Eindruck dass wir
China noch zu irgendetwas zwingen können
über Sanktionen und oder über andere
Regelungen sondern die müssen überzeugen
und wir unsere Werte haben ja auch eine
große Überzeugungskraft aber es ist eben
aufwendiger als früher wo wir das
einfach bestimmen können das geht nicht
mehr die bestens kann die Spielregeln
der Mehrheit der Welt man kann auch
sagen leider die einen sagen leider die
anderen sagen zum Glück nicht mehr
bestimmen das ist die neue Entwicklung
wo ist denn wo sind dann da unsere sehr
die Frage was das dann heißt Herr Dreier
was heißt das sozusagen gibt es da rote
Linien also wenn wir sehen wenn China
zum Beispiel doch Taiwan angreift wenn
wir sehen die Uiguren die in Lagern
eingesperrt sind wir sehen dass die
Demokratiebewegung in hongkonida
geknüppelt wird also wo wo gibt es da
für sie Grenz muss ich sagen nee das
sollten wir jetzt nicht mehr tragen
ich habe bereits gesagt dass China auch
von uns abhängig ist wirtschaftlich
runden Drittel der chinesischen Produkte
die im Ausland abgesetzt werden werden
entweder von den Vereinigten Staaten und
von der Europäischen Union nachgefragt
3,2 Billionen Dollar Auslandsvermögen
sind chinesische Ersparnis die letztlich
fehlen würden wenn
Rentnerinnen und Rentner die dann
bräuchten und wir haben in China ist mit
einer sehr sehr schnell alternden
Gesellschaft zu tun also insofern haben
wir glaube ich schon auch
wirtschaftliches Druckmittel oder
wechselseitige Verflechtung die
hoffentlich in China auch verfängt das
nämlich wirtschaftliche Ziele
hoffentlich stärker gewichtet werden als
sie es im putinischen Russland getan
wurden wo ja der wirtschaftliche Schaden
dort wenig eine Rolle gespielt hat als
die die Ukraine überfallen haben ich
möchte dann dort noch zu dem Dialog
etwas sagen ja dass miteinander redet
ist eine gute Sache es ist aber ein
bisschen die Frage wie man miteinander
redet ja wenn man diese wie Herr sie
ihren sagte man überzeugt
inwiefern überzeugt man kann man den
Herrn Putin überzeugen dass er
bitteschön die Ukraine in Ruhe lässt
kann man mit Argumenten nahelegen das
sei eigentlich eine Katastrophe das sei
auch eine Katastrophe für Russland kann
man das machen nein man kann es nicht
machen auch China Unterschied den pink
hatte schon 2013 ein Konzept
offengelegt das 11 Bereiche der
Gesellschaftsleben Sicherheitsbereiche
sind
einschließlich Kultur einschließlich
Handel alles ist ein Sicherheitsfrage
kann man dann diese Kommunistische
Partei überzeugen bitte sehr nehmen Sie
das nicht zurück nehmen Sie bitte zurück
das ist nicht einzigartig die
Alternative ist es besser nicht zu reden
nein besser ist er wirklich Tacheles zu
reden wie sie sagen ja sie brauchen auch
uns
was heißt denn das jetzt für die Politik
also wenn man sagt wie kann die Politik
die Tacheles reden das ist auch das ist
wirkt also wo gibt es da eben rote
Linien also es gibt ja die
Menschenrechtsverletzungen es gibt die
die Lager in denen die u-kuchen
festgehalten werden und trotzdem machen
wir ja diesen Handel genau einerseits
glaube ich muss man klar beschreiben
worum es bei diesen unterschiedlichen
Themenbereichen geht Tacheles reden ich
glaube dass es überfällig gewesen Heiko
Maas in der letzten Bundesregierung hat
das regelmäßig versäumt es gab auch aus
gutem Grund zeitweise den sogenannten
Menschenrechtsdialog der in regelmäßigen
Abständen stattfand nicht weil man sich
in einer Situation sah erstmal über
andere Dinge Tacheles reden zu müssen
und wenn man das ausklammert und den
Menschenrechtsdialog
durchführt dann hätte die Kommunistische
Partei präsidentie darauf reagiert und
gesagt wir haben klar darüber gesprochen
dann können wir ja das jetzt an anderer
Stelle nicht mehr tun ich glaube was
extrem wichtig ist ist zu zeigen dass
China wenn es jetzt Belege und die gibt
es ja dann großartigem Journalismus
Belege dafür gibt dass es
Konzentrationslager in shinjang gibt und
dass eine un-delegation zumindest mal
hingefahren ist ich hätte mir eine
andere Pressekonferenz von Frau
bacilette gewünscht das sei
dahingestellt das ist aber Konsequenzen
eigentlich geben muss weil China auf
UN-Ebene sich der Allgemeinen Erklärung
der Menschenrechte verschrieben hat es
gab einen chinesischen Gelehrten der sie
maßgeblich mit ausgearbeitet hat zu
akzeptieren dass die Kommunistische
Partei umframed das narrativ umdeutet
dass Menschenrechte einen westliches
Konzept sind ist absolut falsch und ich
glaube das dürften dass wir dürfen wir
nicht zulassen wir müssen widersprechen
Tacheles reden heißt dass der Deutsche
Bundestag sich frei entscheidet über
welche Themen er debattieren möchte wir
sehen uns aber einer chinesischen ein
Programme gegenüber und die verhindern
möchte dass wir eine öffentliche Debatte
ausführen also eine Einflussnahme China
also ich habe in der vergangenen
Legislatur den Menschenrechtsausschuss
geleitet und wenn wir öffentliche
Anhörungen unter anderem auch zur Lage
der Uiguren zur Lage der Menschenrechte
in China insgesamt durchführen wollten
dann hat die chinesische Botschaft in
unterschiedlichsten Büros angerufen
immer wieder auch wörtlich gedroht dass
dass sie sich diese Einmischungen
interner Angelegenheiten das ist ja
immer das narrativ verbitten und hat
dafür sorgen wollen dass diese Anhörung
nicht stattfindet das sorgt natürlich
bei uns selbstbewussten
Parlamentarierinnen und Parlamentariern
eher genau für das Gegenteil dass wir
das noch deutlicher gemacht haben aber
ich glaube das sind die Momente wo man
auch voneinander lernen muss das
passiert nämlich gerade in allen
demokratischen Parlamenten nicht nur ich
habe Briefe vom chinesischen Botschafter
in Deutschland bekommen sondern das
haben meine counterparts in anderen
Länder in der EU in Japan in den USA
genauso bekommen und wir brauchen eine
Strategie dafür und wir brauchen die
Kompetenz ich bin bei hansieren wenn er
sagt wir müssen im Dialog bleiben ich
bin aber auch dabei dass wir viel viel
besser verstehen müssen wie die
chinesische Seite auf die Debatte guckt
wie sie Politik versteht und das haben
wir hier in Deutschland zum Beispiel
noch viel zu wenig Siri das wäre nicht
mal meine Frage wie sehr also ein ein
klares Wort von Deutschland aus dass man
sagt das akzeptieren wir nicht also wie
sehr welche Macht hat Deutschland da
wenn man wenn es nur um reden geht oder
wie wie wird Deutschland da wahrgenommen
doch gar keine Alternative als mit China
zu reden und die Frage wie viel Macht
Zeugungskraft unserer Argumente ab und
auch von den gegenseitigen
Abhängigkeiten aber wenn man es nicht
probiert dann kann man auf keinen Fall
einen Erfolg erzielen und deswegen halte
ich es auch für sinnvoll das Herr Scholz
jetzt Anfang November nach China reist
und ich hoffe dass das sozusagen ein
Dialogprozess dann auch auf der
europäischen Ebene nach sich ziehen wird
so dass man wieder ins Gespräch kommt
ich das muss jetzt der nächste Schritt
sein und zwar von allen Parteien auf
allen Ebenen muss der Dialog wieder
aufgebaut werden auf ein Niveau wie die
Amerikaner in schon haben und dann
müssen wir ihn in diesem Dialog unsere
Chancen versuchen zu nutzen es gibt ja
keine andere Möglichkeit
statt so sitzen und zu sagen naja wie
abhängig sind wir welche Macht haben wir
noch wir müssen uns halt kluge
überzeugende Strategien überlegen wäre
eines wie ich immer da sehen sie nicht
europäischen Politik okay aber die
Amerikaner wenn ich sagen darf die Reden
Tacheles aber Nancy Lucy fährt auch nach
Taiwan also das ist der Punkt wo ich
freue mich wenn Herr Scholz nach China
fährt ich würde mich noch mehr freuen
wenn er auch überlegt welche
Möglichkeiten es gibt an der Seite von
Demokratien in dieser Zeit zu stehen wo
sie unter Druck sind und gefährdet sind
und das ist das was erhalten Bank damit
sagen wollte
auch nicht unterschätzen dazu sagen der
der
in Asien ist die Unterscheidung zwischen
aufsteigenden Ländern und etablierten
Ländern im Westen viel viel stärker als
die Unterscheidung zwischen Demokratien
und
autoritären Systemen das hat man sehr
sehr klar gesehen in
Verhalten zum
dem Angriffskrieg von Putin in der
Ukraine da haben die meisten asiatischen
Länder ob es Demokratien waren oder
nicht ist in diesem Fall egal gewesen
sich entschlossen nicht an den
Sanktionen teilzunehmen im Grunde ist es
am Ende nur noch Japan geblieben die an
den Sanktionen teilnehmen alle anderen
Länder haben gesagt sie wollen das nicht
machen sie wollen sich in den Konflikt
nicht rein das muss man auch sehen dass
natürlich ein Land wie Südkorea eine
Demokratie natürlich auch sehr sehr
stark von China abhängig ist und sich
auch auch kulturell eine Nähe hat zu
China das darf nicht vergessen ich würde
gerne weil wir nicht mehr so viel Zeit
weil wir nicht mehr so viel Zeit haben
deshalb würde ich gerne noch mal
erklären Kollegen
Siren in einen Punkt widersprechen
ich würde nicht sagen dass man nicht mit
anderen redet darum geht nicht auch
deutsche reden ständig mit dem Bettina
über verschiedenen Kanäle reden ist
nicht das Problem das Problem ist wie
man redet und wie sie sagen was du was
das Reden bewirkt die deutschen
verstecken sich oft hinter dem reden
also lass uns dir zu es reden erst mal
passiert gar nicht so sondern solange
wir reden und solange nichts passiert
kann man noch so viel reden der Tag hat
vier und 24 Stunden du kannst auch 24
Stunden weiterreden das passiert nicht
in der Vergangenheit sagen wir mal
Klimaschutz ja hat man was hat man nicht
alles schon mit China besprochen
Klimaschutz klimaschutz ist jetzt aber
auf einem Parteitag verschwunden aus dem
Programm
nirgendwo ist ja noch eine Erwähnung von
Klimaschutz da und ich denke das
natürlich ist es die klimaschutzend das
Thema nicht vorbei die die Unterthemen
sind noch da aber die kommentarische
Partei überlegt sich ganz genau was man
sich internationalen Kontexten sich
leisten kann oder auch nicht leisten
kann es ist nicht so dass die Partei
sich nicht beeinflussen lässt es ist nur
die Frage ob die deutsche Industrie oder
die deutsche Politik bereit ist diese
Einflussmöglichkeit auszuüben und sich
nicht immer dahinter verstecken und
sagen lass uns zuerst reden reden ist
silber schweigen ist Gold Handel ist
wirklich noch viel wichtiger okay
ansprechen also bei china will ja auch
gerne hier Anteil an an Infrastruktur in
Deutschland vergrößern ganz konkret wie
die chinesische Reederei kosko ja ein
Teil vom Hamburger Hafen kaufen ist das
gut wenn wir wenn solche Investitionen
ja wenn wir sagen wir lassen große
chinesische Investitionen hierzu also
wir haben das aus dem wirtschaftsgesetz
jetzt
verschiedentlich nachgeschärft so dass
kritische Infrastruktur
des möglich gemacht wird das
ausländische Investoren nicht einsteigen
obwohl
private Unternehmen ja nach dem
Grundgesetz auch
berechtigt sind ihr privatrechtlich
erworbenes Eigentum veräußern zu dürfen
also hier gibt es schon Regelungen die
verhindern dass kritische Infrastruktur
dass wir nicht einseitig abhängig werden
von einem Land wie zum Beispiel China
aber ich warne auch davor dass wir
aufpassen müssen dass wir nicht von
einem offenen zu einem geschlossenen
Land werden wir werden nicht stärker
dadurch wirtschaftlich nicht Stärke
indem wir uns zu sehr abschotten und zu
dem einzelnen Fall dass das liegt ja im
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium die das
prüfen aber mir wäre noch mal ein Punkt
wichtige Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer
wir haben ja gerade ein technisches
Problem sie sehen das hinter uns jetzt
schwarz geworden ist und wenn sie
gemerkt haben es hat geflackert das lag
nicht an Ihrem Endgerät nur dass Sie
dass Sie das einmal kurz erwähnt habe
also wir brauchen als als Wirtschaft
schon auch politische Rahmenbedingungen
also gute Handelsregeln mit vielen
anderen Ländern die wir heute noch nicht
haben die auch keine leichten das sind
im Sinne von oder auch dass sie wirklich
so gleichgesinnt so like meintet sind
dass wir sagen würden das ist jetzt
genau das richtige Partnerland selbst
mit dem Land was vielleicht uns am
nächsten steht außerhalb der
Europäischen Union mit Kanada haben wir
noch nicht dieses Freihandelsabkommen
unterzeichnet es kommt jetzt ja das
haben wir jetzt schon lang ich glaube
dieses Mal aber was auch wichtig ist die
Europäische Union wir sind anders als
die Amerikaner nicht weltpolitikfähig
weil wir und das schließt die Amerikaner
dann fast mit ein Drittländern
afrikanische Ländern
südamerikanische kein Angebot machen
global Gateway das sind 300 Milliarden
Euro für Infrastrukturprojekte ins
Schaufenster gestellt worden ist noch
kein Euro geflossen während China
gehandelt hat und sagt okay wir bauen
Straßen in Afrika oder oder helfen genau
die Volksrepublik oder die
Kommunistische Partei verkauft diese Art
des Handel als ihre bilaterale
humanitäre Hilfe weil sie schicken nicht
nur sozusagen dass wir die Hausaufgaben
machen
nein das stimmt aber wir können daraus
lernen das ist ich glaube wir wieder in
dem Punkt widersprechen wir uns
überhaupt gar nicht wir müssen unsere
Hausaufgaben machen definitiv aber ich
glaube dass wir ja aber wir brauchen wir
brauchen eigentlich mehr Freihandel mit
den Staaten und ich bin dabei ihnen wir
werden nie einen 100-prozentigen passer
finden es wird in jedem Land gibt es
Probleme oder Herausforderungen wo wir
sagen passt nicht genau aber unterm
Strich gibt es und da sind wir ja bin
ich ihrer Meinung da gibt es glaube ich
viele Länder die darauf warten dass sie
in einen engeren Austausch mit der
Europäischen Union mit Deutschland mit
anderen like meintet gehen und ich
glaube da müssen wir stärker darauf
fokussieren okay wir sind fast am Ende
der Sendung Herr schieben herr Scholz
der Bundeskanzler Anfang November nach
China reist was wir für Sie die
wichtigste Botschaft die ihr da
präsentieren sollte die chinesische
Diskussion zeigt schon also man
diskutiert gar nicht mal über den Bell
und Handel Deutschland ist zwar sehr
wichtig für den Handel aber es ist im
Moment in chinesischen Debatten kein
Thema sondern Thema ist dass die
Geschäfte der Luftwaffe in Japan ist ja
Thema ist was wird in Deutschland machen
wenn in Taiwan irgend irgendwas losgeht
ja also die chinesische Wahrnehmung in
der Diskussionen ist schon klar welche
Botschaft und man von Deutschland
befürchtet dass Deutschland nicht nur
ein Handelssignal sagte okay wir
brauchen euch noch sondern dass
Deutschland diesmal eine anderen Signal
mit dem Gepäck hat und Scholze bereist
nicht nur China sondern gleich auf
Vietnam und Indonesien das sind zwei
Mitbewerber
ich sehe schon wir haben ganz viele
Themen auch noch nicht angesprochen also
zum Beispiel über kohfeld haben wir gar
nicht gesprochen also es gibt eine Menge
was wir einfach noch gar nicht also oder
wo es noch viel mehr
Informationsbedürfnis zu gibt trotzdem
erstmal vielen Dank für diese Runde Herr
Dreier Herr sieren nach Peking
Jensen und Hirschi vielen dank vielen
Dank liebe Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer
entschuldigen Sie dieses technische
Problem wir hoffen dass zu lösen und ich
wünsche Ihnen noch viel Erfolg viel Spaß
bei Phoenix jetzt der Tag mit Michael
Groß krons bis dann tschüss sorry
[Musik]